plus de deux mois après son ouverture
l'unique piste cyclable de martinique
est encore méconnu du grand public comme
des sportifs
le site est pourtant ouvert tous les
jours gratuit et accessible à tous ce
club et famille ce matin ces deux
cyclistes delahaye cfro sont entrés ici
un peu par hasard
après leur entraînement alors premières
impressions bombe on s'est dit bon c'est
un peu court
voilà et pire fin de compte on a été
plus ou moins séduit par rapport au
travail qu'on peut faire dessus et voilà
on a été conquis quand même par le
situer bon c'est une sécurité aussi en
fin de compte il n'y a pas de véhicules
roulent tous dans le même sens et voilà
voilà ça c'est l'idéal pour moi est le
fait que ce soit court c'est extrêmement
roulant et on a tendance à accélérer
donc c'est très bien pour s'entraîner
c'est bien pour faire du cardio donc ce
matin je suis bien contente d'être venue
ici pour les familles c'est bien sûr le
sentiment de sécurité qui prédomine avec
lui et ben on allait souvent vers
l'aéroport
le souci c'est qu'ils avaient beaucoup
de coureurs et aussi les militaires qui
passent en même temps puisque c'était un
peu brouillon d'être d'être en sécurité
puisque chaque fois je restais à coller
à côté de lui pour qu'il n'y ait pas
trop d'intervenants surtout les
cyclistes qui sont déjà habitués qui
passent à vive allure on n'y va plus du
tout parce que depuis l'ouverture de la
piste bien
on vient chaque dimanche maintenant que
j'ai ça madame bello le site comprend
trois pistes reliées entre elles une de
630 mètres pour la vitesse et deux
autres de 400 et 200 m pour la balade et
l'initiation ceux qui font de la
compétition peut venir ici travailler
leurs capacités cardiovasculaires le
fait d'être sur un lieu relativement
plat ça permet de faire un travail
spécifique en vélo quand l'on ne peut
pas faire sur la route ça permet de
exemple de travailler au seuil de
travailler ça vo2max de développer ses
capacités de dire ça de manière
simplement de rouler vite
pendant longtemps la nouvelle structure
fait tout pour attirer les clubs mais
aussi les scolaires attendus dès la
rentrée les éducateurs sportifs encadrés
par le champion hervé arcanes sont là
pour initier les enfants
enfin 30 vélos seront disponibles à la
location à compter du mois de novembre
pour ceux qui veulent essayer